Katy Perry and Orlando Bloom reunite new
info on their budding re up + holy PDA
Batman the singer and his boyfriend
caught in the act and we're with
Hollywood medium himself Tyler Henry
happy hump day friends looks like a pair
of friendly exes are given the
relationship another go I'm talking
about Katy Perry and Orlando Bloom after
breaking things off a year ago they were
spotted together today in Prague
there was PDA and according to a source
the one-time couple of 13 months isn't
just hooking up apparently they're
building a quote new healthy
relationship that is not under the eyes
of their fans and the world they both
live very busy lives and have carefully
made a plan to give their love a second
chance
oh and remembering Katy caught the
bouquet at her brother David's wedding
earlier this month our source says Katy
didn't bring Orlando because they didn't
want to answer questions about their
relationship but adds she was over the
moon when she caught the bouquet Katy
wants marriage and a family well it
looks like that soul-searching did Katy
some good the American Idol judge was
all about the single life when et talked
to her back in October
meanwhile Demi Lovato and Wilmer
Valderrama also caused a stir recently
after they were spotted on a lunch date
could these exes be getting back
together as well the jury is still out
but et is with Demi exclusively tonight
out of tour stop so we're going straight
to the source folks check back here
tomorrow for more on that team and
speaking of teeth how's this for hot and
steamy this PDA from Sam Smith and
boyfriend Brandon Flynn is next level I
mean golly are they hungry did they eat
the couple spending some time in London
where they were snapped sharing that
passionate kiss and a meme account on
Instagram posted a screenshot of a tweet
poking fun at the pic which caught the
attention of Brandon who conveyed his
thoughts with a simple crying emoji
now my overreaction aside I am happy Sam
Smith is happy but now that Sam is in
love what does that mean for his music
so since you're so happy now we're gonna
get happy happy Joe I'll never be that
happy there's always some sadness to
talk about I don't think it's I think
it's melancholy you because the best
songs are the sad ones am i right
Adele okay switching gears now guys
season 3 of Hollywood medium with Tyler
Henry premieres tonight on E and in the
episode Tyler connects Kristin Cavallari
with her late brother Mike who died of
hypothermia in the Utah desert in 2015
our Katie Kraus sat down with the
clairvoyant about the emotional reading
my brother died he got out of his car
and he was walking I don't think he
wanted to be found but did it get to a
point where he got lost out there
Kristin Cavallari
that story was tragic it was
heartbreaking did she get answers kind
of walk me through what happened
Kristin's reading was really special for
me because going into that I had no idea
that her parents were watching the
reading in the other room and when I sat
with Kristin you didn't it did not know
so what messages started coming through
for her dad they made me emotional when
I realized he was watching her reading
was so immersive because this was
someone who died tragically her brother
you know went kind of under mysterious
circumstances and so when he came
through he helped convey what happened
there's an emphasis on two factors
playing on someone's mental stage it's
kind of like there's no saving me
can you talk about what her brother
wanted to convey yeah absolutely I mean
obviously because of the nature of his
passing it was very untimely and he came
through and very much wanted his family
just ill know he was around and he did
this by providing certain validations
about certain things for example there
was a reference I saw like a whole like
wall of license plates and I was like
we're in a mansion there's definitely
not a wild license plates around here I
was describing at Kristen didn't know
what it meant
meanwhile her dad in the other room was
listening and you know exactly what that
meant because he recently had his son
who died birthday and death date
engraved in the license plate and he
knew about that and Christine didn't Wow
Katie actually covers so much more
ground with Tyler including what he says
happens to people in afterlife we'll
have that up for you guys I ET
online.com slash daily Denny alright
thanks for watching and if you like what
you saw today give us a little thumbs up
we'll be back tomorrow with a sneak peek
of Sunday's Academy Awards
you